[Música]
eu gostaria de convidá-los para uma
viagem
fechem os olhos
estamos imaginem que estamos indo para
uma feira livre
vamos pensar as cores da feira livre
os sabores cheiros
achou ninguém olha eu preciso uma cache
olha conhecia
olha eu preciso do abacaxi no olhar
será que se acusa a cdu um quilo delícia
vou levar estamos chegando
abram os olhos chegamos na feira de onde
vieram todas estas frutas legumes
bananas quem produziu essas bananas
quantas mãos quanto trabalho bananas são
é uma fruta muito energética baixo teor
calórico mas ricky cima em minerais e
vitaminas
talvez seja por isso que bananas são
muito usadas pelos atletas
existem em parra tamente no brasil
muitas espécies e delas a gente
aproveita tudo eu disse simplesmente
tudo
usamos a polpa usamos a casca podemos
fazer farofa com a casca podemos fazer
vinagrete com a casca
podemos usar a folha da banana pra assar
peixes e ficam deliciosos
acreditem podemos usar o caule da banana
pra fazer tecidos acreditem tecidos
bananas grandes bananas pequenas bananas
o ouro delícias da natureza e se eu
perguntasse para vocês que cortem o
chuchu
claro que muitos de vocês e responderiam
verdes mas só que não olham
as diferenças de formas de tamanhos de
textura chuchos que a natureza produz
com todas as suas diferenças
estes shows são meio estranhos para os
olhos de alguns estão fora do padrão o
padrão pêra o formato pêra é o padrão
que compramos o que o comerciante
normalmente vende e estes são
considerados imperfeitos anômalos muitos
deles nem chegam na feira porque ficaram
lá no campo porque estão amassadinhos
shortinhos e fora do padrão iguais a
este esses chul vários dos nossos
alimentos vão ficando pelo caminho e vão
se somando uma enorme montanha de
desperdício e o que fazer frente a isso
se esses luxos tem a mesma propriedade
do chuchu padrão pêra incrível porque na
natureza
não existe padrão na natureza o padrão é
a diferença é a diversidade na natureza
a sabedoria está na diferença e viva as
diferenças
esta é a natureza nós somos a a natureza
cada um é um universo continuando a
nossa viagem à feira
eu gostaria de agora que a gente
chegasse à feira depois da xepa e eu vou
mostrar pra vocês
qual é o cenário depois da feira é este
tudo que não compramos o que estava
amassado vai se transformando numa multa
cunha de lixo vejam essas laranjas
será que essa melancia não tem valor
esta e as cascas cascas inteiras de
nutrientes cheias de minerais vitaminas
e tudo que precisamos
porque essa bora está no lixo e jogada
em uma sarjeta
vejam essas mexericas quantas sementes
deixamos por aí espalhadas pela sarjetas
quantas árvores
estamos jogando fora e que foram
esquecidas invisíveis nos caminhos que
vieram de santa fé desde a produção até
chegar nesta feira
quanto trabalho foi desperdiçado
impressionada com esse cenário
eu resolvi pesquisar um pouco mais do
que estava acontecendo nas feiras de são
paulo ea minha pesquisa me revelou
números impressionantes são paulo tem
880 feiras por semana e descarta 33 mil
toneladas de frutas legumes e verduras
tudo isso vai para o lixo vai para o
aterro no final da feira
são números que me impressionaram
enormemente e eu continuei a caminhada
para estudar estes números e quero
mostrar pra vocês um desses números que
andas o número das do das folhas estas
folhas que estão ali jogadas pela
sarjeta folhas e folhas intensas em
nutrientes e e alimento isso não é lixo
são talos são folhas
abba folhas de todas as origens
normalmente nós pedimos para o feirante
não levar a folha do broccoli
a folha da beterraba e folhas que são
alimento 55% daquela montanha que eu
mostrei pra vocês são das folhas que são
alimento e estes números foram me
mostrando um pouco mais
eu fui entender que 95 por cento destas
folhas e da grande maioria das frutas
legumes e verduras são feitas de água e
vejam quando a gente calculou a gente
foi medir o impacto da água que estavam
naquelas folhas enormes quantidades e aí
eu descobri mais um pouquinho vejo tanto
de terra que a gente usou pra plantar
para semear para acolher estas alfaces
cada um desses vegetais e que nunca
chegaram no prato de ninguém de nós tudo
foi para o lixo mil
mais de mil hectares plantados
representando estes números apenas da
feira livre de são paulo
nutrientes quanto os nutrientes jogamos
fora perdemos o um montante que capaz de
suprir mais de 18 mil pessoas por dia de
fibras vitaminas e proteínas e no
inúmeros minerais
gastamos todos é isso todo esse
combustível para levar o lixo que
varremos depois da feira até o aterro de
são paulo
números que só impressiona poluição e
emissões de gases na cadeia inteira
especialmente atmos traduz pela emissão
de gases destas folhas
estes números
me fizeram continuar o estudo e mostrar
e mostraram para mim o que o mundo está
desperdiçando
são estes os números absurdos que
assustadores que por ano vão para o lixo
no dia a cada minuto e na outra ponta
temos 870 870 milhões de pessoas
passando fome que não acessaram uma
grama sequer desse alimento que foi
produzido que foi colhido e que chegou
em algum ponto e que não cumpriu a sua
função de nos alimentar o que fazer como
fazer
onde eu podia começar e eu entendi que
eu precisava aprender e foi buscando
aprender buscando entender que eu
cheguei a um a um ponto que estava logo
ali na minha frente estava na banca
estava no alimento estava na natureza a
natureza tem tanto para nos ensinar que
tudo isso é alimento que a cenoura
rabanete beterraba
ela não é só a raiz eu tenho as folhas
eu tenho alimento em todas as partes que
constituem este vegetal e acostumados
estamos de chegar na prateleira do
supermercado e comprar cenoura bem
limpinha 100 folhas sem raízes e ainda
embaladas e em bandejas de isopor
é assim que estamos buscando os nossos
alimentos cada vez às vezes cortadas até
a mexerica está na bandeirinha
descascada para nossa conveniência
e qual é a solução a solução com esse
aprendizado era gente pensar no resgate
resgate do alimento resgate das nossas
relações com um alimento resgate das da
nossa relação com a natureza resgate com
a nossa cultura com os nossos
conhecimentos tradicionais
eu fui entender que os índios os
bandeirantes
os tropeiros já nos tínhamos nos
ensinado que a técnica para conservar
alimentos pode ser a desidratação e por
que que a gente esqueceu por que estamos
descartando tanto e tanto e tanto se a
gente já tem esse conhecimento eu fui
resgatar das receitas de família que da
casca da mexerica podemos fazer
deliciosas e saborosas geléias doces
quitutes mineiros deliciosos feitos da
fruta da verdadeira fruta
podemos com os fazer conservas
eu chego num ponto de pensar que
precisamos como humanidade reaprender
reaprender com a natureza e aprender com
os outros reaprender com a nossa cultura
com o nosso passado recorrer conectarmos
reconectar mos com toda a sabedoria que
esta beleza é da natureza nos
proporciona descobrir ou redescobrir que
para a natureza não existe resíduos para
a natureza tudo é nutriente tudo tudo é
energia e aqui estava resposta já estava
ali na minha frente e eu
frente a isso continuei a entender que a
gente
num determinado momento se desconectou
porque tudo quase tudo que investimos
quase tudo que comemos quase tudo que
usamos como remédio como cosméticos vem
da natureza ea gente esqueceu que tudo
tudo isso está a nosso a nosso serviço
que a gente vai ter que reinventar a
nossa relação com o alimento alimentos
que supre a vida alimentos que mostram
toda esta maravilha alimentos que nos
proporcionam a integridade e grau mente
nos relacionarmos com a vida
a partir desse desse entendimento dessa
grande descoberta que fiz eu fui
entender que do alimento eu poderia
aquele resíduo eu poderia ter lamentado
muitas pessoas alimentado animais
eu poderia ter produzido biogás eu
poderia fazer compostagem e tantas
outras coisas
e mais eu poderia ainda usar este
alimento para fazer biomateriais querem
ver se eu misturar a tasca da do ovo com
a massa madura do tomate
eu posso fazer borracha borracha
biodegradável que poderia nos ajudar com
o tamanho enfrentamento com o de redução
dos sintéticos poderia fazer
bioplásticos bioplásticos vindo de uma
mão bioplástico vindo do pêssego da
mandioca né
a mandioca tão brasileira e que nos
produtos
essas que nos oferecem essa maravilha
isso aqui já é realidade já existe e
acreditem já existe tecidos
feitos do cogumelo olha que incrível não
é incrível
o cogumelo já nos proporcionam as fibras
do do resíduo desse alimento eu posso
também fazer tecidos tecidos feitos da
fibra do abacaxi tecidos que estamos já
usando toda parte do do abacaxi das
folhas para fazer os sapatos bolsas e
tecidos pesquisador as italianas
descobriram que da casca da laranja elas
fizeram desenvolveram tecidos e esses
tecidos hoje estão nas passarelas
tecidos feitos do requisito da laranja
tecidos tão macios como a seda o que eu
descobri é que isso não é lixo
isto é uma grande usina de
possibilidades que a natureza e coloca a
nosso dispor e com este olhar eu
gostaria de convidá los a continuar esta
viagem comigo e poder para que possamos
acreditar no inacreditável para que
possamos acreditar em outro tipo de
economia em outro tipo de sociedade em
outro tipo de relação com a natureza
porque ela já nos mostrou que é possível
essa reconexão e o que eu gostaria é que
um dia a gente conseguir se entender e
responder prontamente a pergunta que
fruta que estaremos usando hoje e é isso
obrigado
[Aplausos]